[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
emotional testimony as the penalty phase
begins for the man called the daytona
beach killer when i say best friend that
is someone that i can depend on any time
or day
i'm sorry give me a second and patient
care or cold-blooded murder my reaction
was a
surprise
that there were so many patients that
were involved
and also
surprised with one
individual physician a former icu doctor
stands trial for the murder of 14
patients plus a letter from the grave
now means a new trial for a wisconsin
man convicted of his wife's murder
nearly two decades ago but first the
death of brianna taylor you could
actually see bullet holes
i could see broken glass hear testimony
from an officer who responded to the
scene law and crime daily covering court
cases from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome everybody to law and crime
daily i'm brian ross in for brian
buckmeyer who's in kentucky covering the
trial of former louisville police
officer brett hankerson with me in new
york of course is co-host terry austin
and terry we begin with the latest out
of louisville where hankinson is
expected to take the stand soon as the
state rested tuesday afternoon
earlier on tuesday jurors heard from
another officer who responded to the
scene of brionna taylor's shooting death
hankerson is not charged with taylor's
death but instead stands trial on
charges of wanton endangerment for
firing shots into taylor's apartment
that went through the wall into a
neighboring unit it all grew out of a no
knock drug raid on taylor's apartment
back in march of 2020 her boyfriend
believing the officers were intruders
fired at them the officers shot back and
taylor was killed in that crossfire on
tuesday the prosecution called to the
stand an officer who responded to the
shooting he explained to jurors the
moment when he realized the scene was
not a threat
i observed what i believed to be a
window or glass door that had multiple
bullet holes through it
um
and i thought that that was the target
apartment of the
search warrant that had
been served okay so you could you could
actually see bullet holes
i could see broken glass i believe it to
be after
the swat team cleared the actual target
apartment and told us that no one was
inside
we approached the broken glass
was that the first indication that you
had that this apartment was in fact not
a threat to you
uh yes
law encrimes brian buckmeyer has been
covering the trial since it began he
joins us now live in louisville for the
latest in the case brian
brian day four of the testimony of
kentucky versus brett hankinson started
off with some arguments as to whether or
not miles cosgrove's deposition would be
played for the jury next a firearms
specialist testified the prosecution
focused on identification of a target
target isolation and background target
identification all in regards to
shooting at an unseen target cosgrove's
deposition was ultimately played in 16
video clips he explained the dangers of
executing a search warrant in general
then the deposition highlighted what
information had been missing or
overlooked in the planning preparing and
executing of the warrants on briana
taylor's home making it seem like the
officers were ill-prepared after the
deposition chelsea neighbor brown and
taylor's neighbor testified about her
reaction to bullets flying through her
home that was filled with her boyfriend
cody who already testified as well as
her five-month pregnant self and her
younger son with the prosecution resting
late tuesday afternoon the defense's
case is next we expect brett hankinson
to take the stand in his own defense on
wednesday
all right well the defense resting now
uh we expect uh hutchinson will take the
stand dina dahl what do you make of that
it's never an easy call
absolutely not but i think partly it's
because he we already have a police
interview of hinkinson talking about
that night and he seems to say that it
was dark he couldn't see that while yet
he was shooting anyway he needs to
explain that better he needs to say that
he did it because he was defending his
fellow police officer's life and that
there was more intention behind it and
it was not reckless so i think that was
why ultimately him and his attorneys
decided to have him testify
and terry often the judge instructed the
jury that officers cosgrove and
mattingly were unavailable to testify
what do you think that means to the
instructor to the jurors with
instruction that was so vague
well brian you're right it was extremely
vague she just simply said to the jury
look i have an instruction for you don
mattingly and miles cosgrove are not
available so they won't be testifying
and don't use that against any of the
parties she basically explained that
they all requested those to to appear
but they can appear and so i think one
of the reasons that she didn't mention
it she doesn't want the jury to hold it
against anyone so she's making it as
neutral as possible she did mention that
cosgo's deposition would be played and
it was as we know from brian's reporting
right and brian let's take a closer look
at that ex officer cosgrove video did
anything surprising come out of that
brian it was shocking so we already know
before this that brett hankinson was the
canine unit there and his dog was used
for searching drugs but in miles
deposition we found out that what
they're looking for were documents not
necessarily drugs and even the person
conducting the deposition said well
don't you think it's strange to conduct
a midnight raid a midnight search
warrant for documents when you're not
looking for guns or drugs and this is
one of five search warrants and it kind
of gave the impression that this wasn't
necessary even more so than what we
believed that the life of brianna taylor
shouldn't be lost over trying to get
documents in the middle of the night
that was shocking and when you put it to
the rest of
cosgrove's testimony it just seemed like
they had a plan they threw it out they
didn't have all the facts and the
information and this was chaotic from
the start
and it again enforces the idea of why
did we lose brianna taylor to such a
shabby uh
poorly constructed search warrant and
execution of it it's all coming out the
case full of surprising thanks to you
all still ahead on long crime daily a
one-time icu doctor now on trial for the
murder of 14 patients the latest
developments in the trial out of ohio
but first more than 20 years after the
murder of his wife a wisconsin man is
getting a second chance to prove his
innocence our angenette levy is live
with the latest in the case of mark
jensen
[Music]
hi this is dan abrams with exciting news
for all of our law and crime followers
on youtube you can now get the live law
and crime network with youtube tv for
all of your daily live trial coverage
legal news expert analysis and original
true crime programs subscribe to youtube
tv today and then locate law and crime
in the channel guide and for only 1.99 a
month you can add the network to your
bundle watch lawn crime every day with
youtube tv we put you in the jury box
[Music]
and welcome back a wisconsin man serving
a life sentence for the murder of his
wife is getting a new trial because of a
letter from the grave this after the u.s
supreme court refuses to hear an appeal
by prosecutors law and crimes anjanet
levy is here now with more about the
case that's garnered national attention
anjanette
brian mark jensen's appeals have been
heard by state and federal courts since
his conviction in 2008 now more than 20
years after
he was convicted of murdering his wife
he is getting a new trial jensen
appeared in court in kenosha county
wisconsin with his lawyers this week he
has always maintained he did not murder
his wife julie in their kenosha county
wisconsin home back in 1998 and that she
took her own life and framed her husband
prosecutors say mark jensen poisoned his
wife with antifreeze and smothered her
because he was angry about a brief
affair she had had at jensen's new trial
prosecutors will be barred from using a
letter that julie jensen gave to her
neighbor in which she wrote that she
would never commit suicide and that if
she ever died it was because her husband
killed her the argument over this letter
went all the way to the u.s supreme
court which decided not to hear the case
last week the wisconsin supreme court
had already said that prosecutors using
the letter and voice mails that julie
jensen left for a police officer
violated mark jensen's right to confront
his accusers interestingly enough the
judge who allowed that letter and the
voicemails into evidence was judge bruce
schrader who presided over kyle
rittenhouse's trial last year
there's a small segment of the community
that thinks he's innocent um there's
another small segment that throw around
conspiracy theories about
julie framing her husband and then
committing suicides i mean there's
there's all those
things accusations that come with a case
like this but i think the the vast
majority of the community thinks that um
due to the evidence even above and
beyond the letter from the grave and the
voicemails that there's enough evidence
uh to say he's guilty
a new judge is actually assigned to this
case at this point an emotion hearing is
scheduled for november of this year and
then the trial the new trial for mark
jensen is scheduled for january of 2023
brian thanks internet let's bring back
uh co-host terry austin and legal
analyst dina dahl dina the murder in
this case to expect dates back to 1998
more than 20 years before the new trial
is set to begin what kind of
difficulties does that present for
either side
i mean definitely presents difficulties
some of the witnesses may have passed
away
memories may have you know they've
forgotten things in the meantime and
also the emotion of the witnesses of
people who were connected to the victim
that's you know passed as well you know
in terms of the prosecution case but i
also think in these 20 years
society has gotten a lot more awareness
around domestic violence cases um and so
that could help the defense i mean the
prosecution
and terry if the prosecution is barred
from introducing the so-called letter
from the grave how do they build a case
well certainly that letter made it
easier brian but if they're not able to
introduce that letter they're going to
need to focus on physical evidence and
they're going to have to get witness
testimonies and dina's right there won't
be that many witnesses around but as far
as the physical evidence i think the
medical examiner is going to be very
important one of the things that we know
is that she was poisoned and that she
suffocated the medical examiner is going
to have to focus on that suffocation
because you cannot suffocate yourself
your body is going to immediately
respond to that and stop the suffocation
so i think if they focus on that medical
if they get witnesses in who can talk
about what they knew at the time and
then of course the defense can always
cross-examine i think they might be able
to prove the case an engine at this case
seems to be full of surprises unusual
developments conspiracy theories
most definitely and you know lots of
conspiracy theories out there and
a lot of people
some people actually in the community
thinking that this this was um you know
some sort of plot by the wife but then
there are a lot of people who think that
mark jensen was guilty so this is
actually the third judge handling this
case brian
the second judge assigned to the case
actually reinstated the conviction after
a new trial was ordered he did that
without a new trial and then of course
that judge was overturned as well so
this is a case that's got a very long
history with a lot of twists and turns
and we'll follow it closely here thanks
very much coming up on long crime daily
the so-called daytona beach serial
killer facing a possible sentence of
death for the murder of flee f3 florida
sex workers plus end-of-life passionate
care or murder we head to ohio where an
ex-icu doctor is on trial in the deaths
of his 14 patients
[Music]
we head now to ohio for the latest out
of the trial for william hussell a
former icu physician charged in the
murders of 14 patients all of whom
prosecutors say died because they were
given excessive amounts of fentanyl
while being treated
so far testimony for the state has
consisted of pharmacists icu doctors and
other medical professionals who work
with husel at two of the mount carmel
hospital branches in columbus ohio
between 2015 and 2018. the jury has
heard testimony about fentanyl dosages
and the amount an expert says led to the
patient's deaths a pharmacist who worked
at the mark carmel west branch testified
thursday
saying he a huso was named in risk
management reports for using high doses
of fentanyl he also told the jury about
a night pharmacist who expressed
concerns over the dosage being
administered to patients
i directed him
to
contact our
quality and risk management individual
katie barga
and alert her that we had a concern
and
that we needed to look further into it
to find out the circumstances of it
so that we would know if it was
a serious problem or just
just a general report in in my uh
capacity i often heard
uh people would come and tell me they
have a concern about
a particular drug or whatever or the use
of the drug
and uh so normally the first thing we
have to do is get more information on it
and understand why the doctor prescribed
it and what was the patient's
circumstances
before we
move into a larger
investigation terry austin based on the
testimony of the pharmacist so far how
does it shape up in terms of hustle and
whether he violated any protocols
well listen brian so far it does seem
like he's violated protocols first of
all he's using prescriptions that most
people don't use most of those doctors
prescribe morphine versus fentanyl and
the fact that he used such high doses so
it does seem that he's going above and
beyond what the protocols are but the
best physician who was up on that stand
he was actually a pharmacist it was john
o'connell who we just saw he was very
impactful he basically was the director
of pharmacy at the time and he said he
was concerned about the fact that the
amount of drugs was so high there were
so many patients and it all came down to
this one physician and so i think he was
very clear that there was something
really wrong here and he also made it
very clear it wasn't the job of the
pharmacist to prescribe it was the job
of the physician very damaging testimony
indeed dina this case is scheduled to
last at least eight eight weeks and it's
weighed down by heavy medical testimony
should there be a concern by both sides
about the jury's attention span
yes and that's something attorneys
always take into consideration i mean
serving on the jury is very important
but it's also a sacrifice and they try
to be cognizant of using that time but
there are 14 murders here the
prosecution has to prove each one that
is just going to take a while and
although it drags it out maybe in terms
of the juror's mind it also becomes much
more persuasive that his actions weren't
just a coincidence because we're going
to see a pattern he is going to done
a very similar thing in each of the
deaths so ultimately that
culminative evidence helps the
prosecution quite a bit an eight-week
trial all right when we come back the
courtroom gets heated as the penalty
phase continues for the man called the
daytona beach serial killer
why did convicted killer robert hayes
clench his fist in the courtroom that's
still ahead on long crime day
and welcome back the penalty phase is
now underway for the so-called daytona
beach serial killer just one week after
robert hayes was found guilty on three
counts of first degree murder
hayes was convicted of killing three
women investigators say were sex workers
in daytona beach florida the killings
happened between 2005 and early 2006.
investigators linked haye's dna to the
three shooting deaths after the murder
of a fourth woman rachel bay in west
palm beach 10 years later hayes faces
separate charges in bay's murder and
will be tried for that at a later date
on monday the penalty phase began for
hayes who now faces the death penalty
jurors heard testimony from hayes mother
sister and college best friend who broke
down crying while speaking to attorneys
i'm actually
robert's daughters his first child
godfather
so when i say best friend that is
someone that i can depend on anytime or
name
um
i'm sorry
later hayes himself gets visibly upset
in the courtroom when the defense shows
a picture of his
daughter it's very upsetting i've been
very clear that i'm not going to hear my
children okay uh
viewers showed any of this especially
since you've been showing
the show on youtube and on this
channel
[Music]
nothing like that i was very upset at
that well i saw you clench your fist and
that cost me some concern
all right gina that was strong testimony
from hayes best friend powerful
emotional but was it enough to take the
death penalty off the table
probably not i mean
we reserve the death penalty for the
most egregious crimes he is convicted
now of killing three women so he
definitely qualifies for it that
evidence did show his character that
this was maybe unlike his character and
also maybe to have some compassion his
sister spoke about how difficult it was
to grow up in their house and how he was
molested as a child all those things the
jury will take into consideration that
maybe he should be in prison to allow
some sort of redemption that there may
be some kind of compassion hope for him
but ultimately this is the kind of case
that if you want to apply the death
penalty it would be in a case like this
terry austin the judge as we heard said
he saw hayes clenching his fist you
think the jury's getting a glimpse of
his temper
well maybe so i really wonder if they
saw it i was watching the trial intently
i did not see him do it but the judge
absolutely did it was a very interesting
moment the judge literally stopped the
proceedings he said
during dr wu's testimony let's pause and
dr wu actually had a powerpoint where he
was showing all of the causes as far as
why hayes may have behaved the way he
did and he showed a picture of the fact
that his daughter has autism and when
that picture showed that was when hayes
clenched his fits that was when the
judge said let's stop the proceedings at
that point council apologized and said
listen i didn't mean to put the picture
in and at first the judge basically said
well mr hayes if you want to leave the
room you can and then haze explain no i
don't want that picture to be shown and
so i think the judge understood at that
point that perhaps they shouldn't show
the picture and they did allow dr wu to
continue testifying without showing any
other pictures in that powerpoint but if
the judge saw that brian i really do
think or rather if the jury saw it i
really do think it's going to influence
their opinion absolutely of course they
get great attitude in deciding the death
penalty any one person can knock it out
well thank you all for joining us we
appreciate it very much we'll see you
next time as we continue to discuss
justice in america
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you